In lots of applications, you need to read many inputs. Here, when you look at
these adorable kittens, of course, you want to pet them all. But if you're a
vet, you might also need to know their weight, their average weight, which
one's the largest, which one's the smallest, and so on. So, a program that
processes data like that needs to read in all of that information. It needs to
specifically, in this case, read in the weight of every kitten. So, we might
want to prompt to enter the first weight, the user enters first kitten weighs
100 grams. We get the prompt for the second weight, the user enters, prompt for
the third weight and so on. Well, when do we stop? Maybe we could have asked
the user how many values are you going to enter? Now, that's a little clumsy,
particularly when there's lots of values. There's a common solution to this
problem. And that is to ask the user to enter some input, that definitely can't
be the right value. In this case here, we might ask the user to enter 0,
because no kitten can weigh 0 grams. Such a value is called a sentinel value.